hey etsy it's the ladies of the collab
crib and today we're bringing you into
our world is black creators on tick tock
[Music]
hey ladies y'all looking good
girl group over here all right
yes so we know you are creators who are
part of the collab crib
but tell us about yourselves
individually we'll start with uk
show what are your dreams what are your
hopes i want to be a movie you want
being tv
i want to be like in like tv series and
stuff like that
but yeah i do tick tock instagram
youtube so like the whole social media
thing
i ain't never seen two pretty best
friends thanks ugly
it's a video you ain't never seen a
video before no cuz you over here
talking about some facts who ugly
it ain't me it ain't me wow so i'm the
ugly friend y'all think i'm the ugly
friend
okay yo i ain't saying that she said
that i didn't even say that
my friend like i'm an artist
full-time yeah the social media was just
something i kind of just jumped into
because
it's 2021 you know like you have to
everyone has to be on social media at
this point to get the music across
hey theo you hear that bro thank you
[Music]
yeah i want to double and dabble in like
you know fashion or
i maybe you might catch me acting a
little bit or something but
this is the music all right kumara tell
us a little bit about yourself and your
hopes and dreams i want to be an actress
for sure like disney nickelodeon
perry like yeah girl that's tyler perry
needs to happen right now
you're in atlanta i can see it i can see
it too yeah and she has what's again
sir i know you're the baby of the group
how was that
um it's good yeah it works she doesn't
work like she's younger than us
right she works the same
[Music]
other than the fact that you're black
creators inside one house
what do you think sets you apart from
the other houses on the west coast like
the sway house in the hype house what
makes you different
more so our energy i know it's hard to
separate the fact that we're black but
you know black people we have to work a
little harder for everything
so we already know that we're not being
set to the same benchmarks and standards
and moves as most of these other houses
are
on the west coast or whatever mostly
because we're coming in at a
disadvantage
and we're already under being underpaid
you know you never been under treated as
creators
so i think it's just our work ethic as
black
creators so that being said kshell
do you feel like there's any pressure to
live up to the success
of the other houses or do you you guys
just do you
i feel like most of the most of us here
we do us
because like if you're focused on the
next person then you can't really like
be as successful as you want to be but i
mean sometimes
you know you do you know you do look a
little bit but
for the main part we just focus on us
and just make sure that we have
everything we need
to be successful well camara being a
content creator it seems like a
full-time
job hats off to you three
what keeps you motivated to keep the
content coming
it's really just like where i want to be
in life like it's always been my dream
to do this like and my mom always told
me to follow my dreams so
it's a full-time job i'm going to admit
um but i mean if it's really what you
want to do you just got to be
like have the drive for it well what are
some of the issues as black creators on
tick tock
do you feel that needs to be addressed
on the platform
she can start oh she can oh you know i'm
actually dealing with one
um right my page was actually it said
banned for some reason and like before
it was banned like
all of my videos that i was trying to
pose it just kept getting like flagged
my kid being taken down says community
guidelines and i wasn't really doing
anything like hey shell had posted the
same video on her page
i had the same exact video on my page in
the state so i don't i'm so confused i
don't get it have you received any
answers
they said that it's something about my
age they say that i gotta be on the 13
and under app but i'm actually 14 so it
doesn't really
make sense they said that i can't get my
page back and just for everyone watching
this is an issue that a number of black
creators have been facing recently
right so so how are you moving forward
with this
camaraderie um i'm just going to have to
start from the bottom up again
i created me a new page no are you
serious yes like i had just hit like
400k
and it took me years to get there but
now
you know all i can do is just pray and
just work
is there a way that they can reactivate
it or is the way
there's
sometimes some setbacks are setting you
up so for
for better things that's
that's wild all right well let's talk
about the appropriation of black culture
on tick tock
julia harmon she created the renegade
right but charlie the emilio got most of
the credit for it
so as black creators on the platform you
are obviously working very hard
and as you said you might not get the
same shine as houses on the west coast
how do you process that and keep going i
feel as if okay i do understand that
black creators
are trans status for a lot of you know
the content
that is being produced on tick tock but
at the same time
there's a way to involve yourself in
someone's culture without
it becoming cultural appreciation so how
to
necessarily address it it's i
honestly couldn't give you an answer
mostly it's kind of just like
you want people to appreciate us but at
the same time
it's a fun i think it's more in the
educational background where they
have to educate themselves before they
can
and like you know be involved it's
definitely
really frustrating i can't sit here and
say it's not sometimes it does mess with
your mental because you're like well dag
like
because you're trying so hard and you're
doing exactly the same thing as other
people but for some reason it seems like
you're being targeted or
you're being like hated or something
like that you know but
i mean the most we can do you can't sit
there and you can't like you know dwell
on the situation
you can't like beat yourself up because
you won't get anywhere so even though it
sucks
the most we can do is just work harder
so yeah pretty much
yeah well they need to come with that
same energy that they come with for us
like they take our stuff down and then
right
and also the algorithm issues have you
all heard of that oh my gosh
we're experiencing it right now tell us
okay so this this is about awareness too
you know the more people that know the
more action hopefully will be
taken so tell us your thoughts on that
and what's going on there
yeah okay so recently i posted a video
and it was at zero views for like over
an hour so i posted the same video again
it was at zero views for an hour and i
posted it again zero views so then i
made a video basically explaining like
i have 1.4 million followers why is it
and it didn't say that they
violated community guidelines so i'm
like what is the issue if you're going
to do this at least explain to me what
the problem is so that i would be able
to fix it
so i made a video basically explaining
how i felt like it was unfair that
i didn't have the opportunity to show my
content zero views
so i posted another video was like well
hey you guys just go to my instagram so
you can see the video
zero views i don't understand what the
issue is
but and it's like if we're going to get
like strikes for community guidelines at
least
have like at least be able to tell us
what we're doing wrong you know
don't just take it down like it's like
um scolding the child and not telling
them what they did wrong they're not
right so tick tock has not reached out
to you
about that as creators no and is this
something like if you're to be honest do
you think that this
is just something black creators are
dealing with
um i would say it's hard to say to just
pimping it at black
creators but to a certain extent i when
we experience it
it's like we all understand because
we've all been in that spot
yeah talking to creators that aren't
black don't
seem like i can say it does i will say
what happens to everybody but i feel
like the black community gets it the
worst
yeah for sure there's research that
people have done to back that up too so
yeah yeah that's a lot to take in but on
a positive note camara let's talk about
some
favorite black creators who are on the
platform who you might feel like don't
get enough shine
one of them will be for sure question
really
that's cute what do you want your fans
and followers to take away from your
content
um i want them to know that it's okay to
speak up for yourself if you feel some
type of way say what you got to say
yeah i want honestly i just want people
to feel inspired
because i came a long way to get where i
am
like physically and mentally so
if i can make someone smile for two
minutes out of the day
i've done my job
it's not the same thing what uh caitlyn
says like
you just want them to feel inspired you
want them to feel good about
at
yourself
[Music]